Iran's president Ibrahim raisi has
arrived in Kenya it's the first visit by
an Iranian leader to Africa in more than
a decade Rousey and the Kenyan President
William Ruto are set to discuss trade
the trip is widely seen as an effort to
reduce Iran's economic isolation as a
result of U.S sanctions he will then go
on to visit Uganda as well as Zimbabwe
let's speak to Catherine Sawyer who's
monitoring this trip out of Nairobi
Catherine so what exactly are we
expecting from the two leaders today
well the two presidents are held a press
conference a little a little earlier and
they talked about uh this deal uh this T
these uh trade deals uh that they have
made uh including communication
technology tourism agriculture education
and Mining as well so President William
Ruto uh said that he is Keen to form
more uh strategic Partnerships with uh
Iran and he also said that he hopes to
expand and deepen ties between the two
countries arising on his part I said
that he wants to create more
opportunities and he also talked about
this issue of sanctions that have been
imposed on Iran and the president said
that he despite those sanctions
um Iran is still moving on
and the two sides actually benefit from
each other
well the main issue was this a trade the
president talked a lot about this deals
and how they can strengthen this ties
um you know we know that President Ruto
has been going around different
countries trying to get EX investment
from these countries and this is because
of different issues that have been
happening in Kenya for example Kenya is
struggling economically the government
has been
um you know trying to balance its books
which has been very difficult the
government is also struggling to service
this huge external debt so the president
is under a lot of pressure to perform
um that we have seen protests in Kenya
actually today there's going to be a
opposition protest as well so the
president is trying very much to get
other countries invest in Kenya so that
you know the country can improve but
then also we have been talking uh to
um we have been talking to analysts who
say that on the part of President rice
is that he's trying to form uh this uh
alliances in different countries because
of what's going on in his country uh
politically
um that his country has been he's uh he
has been isolated
um internationally there's the issue of
the sanctions that I talked about as
well so perhaps that is one of the
reasons why the president raisy is
trying to move and make more alliances
not just
um in Africa but other countries as well
okay thank you for that Catherine soy
there for us live in Nairobi